I would like to forcefully reiterate once again
the total and
unconditional solidarity with France yesterday as
President Cruz just reminded
Valeria Soresini said goodbye to Venice an Italian girl a
European girl whose young life
was cut short with brutality and
together with that of 129 other people,
the free movement of people,
put under pressure
both by the migratory phenomenon and by the
threat of terrorism, as I mentioned, has as its
logical corollary and strengthening of
collaboration between the member countries
more responsibility more initiative a
more than cohesion
only in this way will we be able to overcome the
arrogant challenges that terrorism brings right
into our coffers
the European Union represents in
the international context and
in the collective imagination a point of
reference for every person, people or
state that bases your existence on
peace  between nations on freedom and
respect for citizens' rights